[Musique]
il y à une nouvelle ballerine dans le
casse toi êtes des grands ballets
canadiens et elle n'est pas comme les
autres comme vous dites je peux je n'ai
pas le physique typique dabrin j'ai un
physique très athlétique et ça m'a été
par reprocher mais on le fait beaucoup
remarquer dans ma carrière et j'ai
décidé d'en faire un atout
vet remarquer mohd sabouret a commencé
sa carrière aux ballets de monte carlo
elle y est resté pendant 12 ans et on
l'a nommé ce lobbyiste principal moi
j'étais comme une éponge
j'ai absorbé le plus possible c'était un
gros gros challenge
j'aimais beaucoup d'opportunités voyager
à travers le monde dansait sur des
terres magnifiques avec des gens
incroyables
originaire de terrebonne mode sabouret
vient tout juste de se joindre aux
grands ballets canadiens
son physique tout en muscles et en
souplesse est le fruit d'un entraînement
particulier et j'ai commencé à combiner
les deux entraînements ensemble et je
suis rendu compte que c'est amener mon
niveau de performance tellement plus
élevé les blessures tellement moins
fréquentes et j'avais l'impression que
ma la machine était juste au top top de
sa forme et je me suis dit pourquoi pas
faire passer le message aussi au public
parce que je pense qu'elle fait vraiment
quelque chose qui peut changer la vie
des dards sauf pour que chaque muscle
soit bien développé et en santé la
danseuse géré midi curieusement son
alimentation
je mange beaucoup qui beaucoup de
les soirs je mange beaucoup d'oeufs
quand même on n'avait pas ça comme banal
et ça m'a jamais il faut manger on est
des athlètes de haut niveau il faut que
nourrissent nos muscles c'est primordial
j'écoutais un petit peu excessif j'adore
le côté sculpturale du conte donc ça
c'est plutôt dans la nutrition des doses
j'adore ce qu'on mange mange chaque
élève
grâce à son corps bien entraîné mood
sabourin interprétera cette rôle dans
casse noisette c'est un grand rêve de
petite fille qui se réalise ce que je me
souviens la première fois que j'ai vu
que ce soit avec ma maman
ça m'a donné la piqûre et sous les
ballerines
et la petite fille a gardé ce rêve comme
un trésor parce que trop longtemps elle
s'est fait dire qu'elle ne pourrait pas
le réaliser
j'aimerais être un exemple pour les
petites filles à qui on dit c'est pas
possible
combien dans une boîte quand on m'a dit
que je ferais jamais titi quand j'étais
petit ça m'a brisé un peu le coeur mais
aujourd'hui je porterai un titi pour
casse noisette donc voilà possible ici
oui j'ai déprimé radio canada montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]